da tutti per grasso e benvenuti di nuovo
annuncio o video bellissimo di sopra
ritmo e forever è bello adesso a tempo
se devo rimanere dentro un corso a tempo
se non vuoi ok va bene che ogni volta
c'è una dinamica nuova quindi immagino
ci sono anche ci sono anche le schifose
mi ci sfugge perché dovrei morire dentro
cespuglio poi ma scusami c'è un pezzo
senza no devi saltare questo fatto non
so neanche come va bene madonna ragazzi
veramente marsi alla clinica poiché
musica è questa va bene va bene perfetto
perfetto perfetto effetto degli yes
ma mi faccia il dito medio c'è melone
c'è questo super meat boy ragazzi non è
per riprendere altra volta uno
scoiattolo set altra ma ciò non è very
friendly c'era la balena e non esiste
sai cosa altro che le perenni trentino
tra un po sporca d'altro non riesco a
capire perché ogni tanto si macchiano di
sangue le cose ma non le tocco mi sento
parte una particina di sangue contro le
cose come ho fatto un fenomeno un
fenomeno un fenomeno un fenomeno però
meno proprio lui ho fatto troppe cose
incredibili e da sola era già assurdo
col fatto che va avanti da solo in un
casinò che lo dico c'è molto più
difficile
all'inizio pensavo fosse una dinamica
diversa difficoltà uguale
richiedo tutto leggo il fatto che lui
decideva ad andare avanti e più
difficile devi essere di avere un
tempismo che non ha eguali
altro che il primo super meat boy ok
non trovate ok
mamma mia che kim ok perfetto un
fenomeno un fenomeno proprio lui
no penso l'ho fatto in tempo undici
morti non sono niente stato bravissimo
scusate me lo devo prenderla a pugni
mentre ho arrangiato ok bellissimo non
avevo intuito subito
volevo andare un pò in alto all'inizio
devo calcolare quanti anni devo darli
per noi
ok mamma mia che casino
cioè si stanno aggiungendo un sacco di
minami dei ragazzi no non vedo l'ora che
finisca asta dinamica perché i flussi
sono dal fastidiosissimi fastidio ed è
una rottura di palle perché poi non
capisci anche quando te quando esci 1234
è difficilissimo prenderli a pugni si
cosi ok va bene non solo non fate pasta
roba cercate allora più che altro il
timing ragazzi ct coste va beh non so
come ho fatto una paese
no dai fratello fi serio
madonna che culo perfetto
ma dove non ci credo ho fatto una roba
che non volevo neanche fare ma l'ho
fatta va bene morto
non so neanche come ho fatto a questo
casino male di porta
va bene bellissimo proprio io proprio io
27 morti quando andata molto peggio
ragazzo è stato un disastro su scala
globale
la clinica la vedo un po più cazzuta è
non so come mai a questi devo sfondare a
pugni metri va bene questo che
ambientazione veramente core che già
questo supermicro rispetto all'altro
veramente più presto
guarda che disastro ho fatto una provata
lega
ho fatto una provata potrebbero anche
solo un problema perché devo fare matic
bastavo power tante mi è basta guarda
guarda ma dopo fatto è un fenomeno
il problema dei bimbi no non so cosa sto
facendo ma sono molto mezza volta guarda
mar
tutto lui tutto lui il fenomeno burgener
del secolo cosa sto facendo basta sul
fenomeno sono più morto non morire
adesso non perdere la sua propaggine
dimostra il popolo che ti meriti 6
milioni di iscritti previsioni a posto
sono soddisfatto ok finché non si apre
quello su un ponte anno devo farlo per
questo siamo messi non si spaccano va
bene lo apro e corro con un puledro
corico un puledro a posto non ho che è
tornato indietro non è tornato indietro
dai o non sono più morto da un'ora
raga perfetto cliccate come possibile
addio non sono più morto da un'ora
pazzesco no ce l'ho fatta c'è un'ansia
terribile
ok no raga per ho fatto a metà a livello
in cui non sono più morto c'è un
fenomeno un fenomeno e randa duale che
non morivo prova a farla ragazzi con
bender che alla fine la stessa cosa
cambia nulla ragazzi non livello prova a
farlo con lei così almeno ascoltiamo
anche l'altro personaggio a questi
quelli di riprendere a cui più volte
perché non muoiono subito il carico è la
madonna
ok tutta la città in regola tutto il re
tutto in regola morto per caso e che era
nota benissimo ecco le faccio qua perché
le botte riesco a superava le molte note
lo proprio da lì in pugno all'ultimo ok
a questo l'ho fatto abbastanza in questo
era molto più facili voli prima sesto
livello al penultimo switch charlus
richard poi c'è il boss ragazzi
modifiche di vento vediamo cosa mi
quello a serve per attivare le cose ok
ma qui ci sono degli interruttori che
puoi attivare
buono a sapersi tutto questo molto bene
però non gli devo più attivare perché
sennò poi nella prende intercooler fa
niente e fantasma fastidioso non ci
arrivo al muro come ci arrivo ok non è
partito per ora
porca [ __ ] o è un disastro ignazio
incredibile ok cioè se stavolta sua
fatta no il fantasma non ci voglio
credere lega è veramente passato di
autostop
cribbio di fantasma ed ai ce l'ho fatta
si no
no nella vita no no no no no no ho messo
gioco come cacchio come sono morto santo
iddio come ho fatto dai raga non c'è
prometterci è finita è finita è finita
finita finita finita ciao ciao ciao sono
morto finale due ore due voglio mai
rimpiango quelli che mi mangiavano
esplodi tu e gli altri boss
sicuramente un tasso poteva fare ciò
nessuno questo è stato quello più brutto
da quando c'è questa roba
madonna boss finale non lo so pensare il
box ragazzi non lo fa non lo voglio
pensarlo sembra tutto in regola
cosa sta facendo
la ficcato in un barattolo no c'è un
blog
e adesso ma ragazzi bella cosa meno
family friendly che esista più pro non è
bene non lo è
il gioco non lo è e va beh la madonna
la vedo grigia credo che debba colpire
con le in mezzo
[Musica]
ma poverino aiuto ma devo correre qua
poi diverso con rivas bene no mori lo
devo centrare punto del game nome è
imbarazzante
non esiste possibilità che io possa
battere questo affare da zero da zero da
zero da zero non ci sono i check point
ho finito qualche provino ragazze ma
porco del demonio non la vedo proprio
fattibile ok e mi è andata ancora bene
il problema grosso è che non ci sono i
check point cioè non posso andare a culo
tutta la vita
[Applauso]
dio ti ringrazio mamma mia che roba
fuori di testa penso che non ci sia
stato boss dall'inizio di super meat boy
anche dell'altro così difficile orribile
impossibile ragazzi che bossi fatti
pazzesco che è roba incredibile ragazzi
sono le casse scioccato
non ho distrutto niente un miracolo
tranne lui o lui morto con culo tra cui
uno scoiattolo col braccio mozzato
attenzione che ha sepolto tutti e ove
ramoscello no perché scena incredibile
l'orda di scoiattoli beh spero siano
nostri alleati visto quello che è
successo a ce lo stanno portando alla
volta in guerra lui è perfetto
[Musica]
raga ma che cacchio è probabile sia
piaciuto questi ragazzi dice lotito mi
piaceva di sapere che il commento qua
sotto quale sarà secondo voi il plot
twist dello scoiattolo succederà con lo
scoiattolo perché sono curioso anch'io
ero ci vediamo al prossimo bisogno di
super miccoli da ragazzo
[Musica]